so how did you be Conan oh well sorry
um
I met Robert Smiggle through my friend
Beth Cahill who was on SNL right when I
was in New York doing The Brady Bunch
and then we just hung out a little bit
then when I was in LA uh doing The Brady
Bunch he came out because he was working
on the ill-fated Hans and Franz movie ah
so that was his SNL he was you know
wrote on SNL was a producer on SNL and
that was his summer and we hung out a
lot then Conan got the job Robert was
his head writer executive producer
reached out to me said which just is you
know a show like that starts and then
it's like who's out there
doesn't have a job that's funny and I
was one of those people and I submitted
some stuff and got and I was the first
writer hired on the show and the Conan
and I met
at Junior's Deli here and we figured out
that we had actually been at a party at
Bob odenkirk's house whoa because Bob
and Conan did shows at SNL together and
I had been on teams with Bob's improv
teams with but then Bob's fiancee so I
knew Bob that way uh and I we've been at
Bob's house with like 12 other people
and just didn't register each other yeah
you know and uh and we hit it off very
very much at Juniors and uh he you know
Robert and him both told me that he
called Robert and said hire the guy and
Robert was like let's see you know they
hadn't seen me right you know I hadn't
sent in anything yeah yeah so you served
as a writer yeah yeah I had that was
another thing it's like so much stuff
that gets thrown at you stuff that you
you don't know how you know hey write a
packet for a late night sketch show yeah
like you know now I bet kids are
reading articles on the internet about
what to do and they're learning it
probably in college yeah for me I was
like oh gosh what would I like just I
think it's almost better that you don't
know much about it yeah yeah I think so
too I think so too especially
especially in comedy uh because you want
a spark you want originality you want
somebody that's that's thinking about
what hasn't been done yeah yeah you know
and also to anybody that's anybody that
gets too big on and I found this when I
came out here and started working on
sitcoms
and there's just a appreciable
difference of like
of just there's a lot more protective
attitude towards people's careers out
here where they're like much more
careful where it was more just like have
fun and around was always what we
would do in late night I like that too
oh it's so good but then I around
guys I get I get on in a writer's room
on a sitcom and it's like a lot of stuff
but like well slow down you gotta
understand the structure yeah it's like
yeah I've seen sitcoms I know how they
work set up the bit and there's an a
plot and a b plot and they're about 22
minutes long and then you fill them with
Jokes which if you were better at you
wouldn't worry so much about stuff yeah
like for
I the night before I auditioned I got my
agents my manager's like listen they're
not really seriously considering you but
that's so good luck that's what she said
because they're like they're looking for
a white guy you know how back then they
you know I mean right right but you know
you could not get a white guy on TV